I'm gonna tell you about how the drug  war in Mexico began  and it was boss Miguel felix cardona  croquet on traffic artemis poderoso in  mexico agent Camarena  welcome to Guadalajara villas Kyoto  crosses the DEA for the last time  tonight  but the attorney was in here every  second counts Kiki so Shannon within  that scene that has a spotless  we're running out of time  [Music]  mr. Lavoie akhantar rosovsky to tampoco  I'm putting my life into this job what I  want to see is change what are the  posters available sir  what do you have I'm tired of this thing  I am too so let's change it take Mexico  Kiki agent coming in welcome to  Guadalajara you're the best agent we  have I need you can take down the wall  shots  hey tell this guy he's the boss  where do we get started sheet villas  pirate across was the DEA for the last  time tonight  the technique without feelings on my  name  you will one day  you  you